des fleurs pour jérôme la rose depuis ce
matin famille proche ou connaissances
viennent se recueillir devant son
ancienne ferme de trivy le 20 mai 2010
est cet éleveur est en cavale depuis
neuf jours ils fuient un énième contrôle
sanitaire de son exploitation
son véhicule est repéré à quelques
kilomètres de chez lui deux gendarmes de
cluny le retrouve sur un chemin isolé
selon les militaires le fugitif aurait
tenté de foncer sur eux pour s'échapper
des coups de feu sont tirés trois balles
touchent mortellement l'éleveur dans le
dos et sur le flanc il faut que que la
vérité sorte et faune et donc faut que
les qui est un soutien pour pour la pour
la famille pour les gens qui s'en
occupent
la famille ne croit pas à la thèse de la
légitime défense invoquée par les
gendarmes
une instruction est ouverte pour
violences avec arme ayant entraîné la
mort sans intention de la donner en 2018
la famille dépose deux nouvelles
plaintes la première pour non assistance
à personne en danger
la deuxième pour modification de la
scène de crime
depuis la famille laronze a l'impression
que l' enquête s'enlise et on a très peu
de contacts avec les juges d'instruction
également c'est un grand regret moi je
leur ai écrit un long courrier très
argumenté en mars 2019 et à ce jour je
ne les ai pas rencontrés je n'ai pas eu
de réponse
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi à une
consternation d'une distance qui
s'établit entre le travail du juge
d'instruction et les parties puisque en
tant que partie civile nous sommes une
partie au dossier le procureur de la
république de chalon sur saône n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur cette affaire
l'instruction judiciaire étant toujours
en cours de son côté la famille de
jérôme larron se dit combative et
vigilante sur l'aboutissement de ces
enquêtes